for years scientists have been
developing systems to allow people who
can't speak to communicate with their
minds these brain computer interfaces
attempt to translate patterns of brain
activity into words and sentences
back in 2021 this was the state of the
art a setup that allowed this
participant to talk at a rate of 15
words per minute with a vocabulary of 50
words
two years later a pair of teams have
made rapid progress
the new studies show off systems that
enable their two participants to speak
at over 60 words per minute with
comparatively fewer errors and larger
vocabularies than ever before this
research could be the groundwork needed
to take brain computer interfaces like
these out of the lab and start
developing practical and potentially
life-changing technology
[Music]
this is Pat she has ALS or amyotrophic
lateral sclerosis which impairs Her
speech and facial movements and she's
been working with a team of
neuroscientists based at Stanford
University to help develop their brain
computer interface
when Pat tries to speak the neurons in
Her speech motor cortex activate
this is the part of the brain that
controls the muscles we use to speak a
series of microelectrode arrays inserted
into Pat's brain can read the activity
of over a hundred individual neurons
these readouts then go into a machine
learning algorithm
during training sessions Pat tries to
read out specific phrases
[Music]
and the algorithm learns to match the
sounds she's reading with the patterns
of neuronal activity
this data is then fed into a language
model with a vocabulary of over a
hundred thousand words which figures out
what words those sounds are most likely
to represent
training Pat could communicate at around
62 words per minute much faster than
previous setups and with a much larger
vocabulary and fewer mistakes
oh
[Music]
hello how are you
the researchers say that using more
electrodes reading activity from more
individual neurons could make their
system more accurate and provide even
more information about how different
parts of the brain actually work
meanwhile a second team from the
University of California San Francisco
are tackling this challenge with a
slightly different approach
their system reads brain activity from
the surface of the brain and again can
use a combination of a machine learning
algorithm and a language model to decode
that brain activity successfully into
text with a vocabulary of around a
thousand words or so and a rate of up to
78 words per minute
but as well as producing text this
system can produce the sounds of speech
spoken by this moving Avatar be afraid
to ask me questions
the Avatar isn't just reading out the
decoded text instead another algorithm
has been trained to translate brain
activity directly into sounds great to
see you were dead
the idea is that this speech isn't
limited to certain words and could
potentially allow someone to vary the
tone and speed of their speech in a much
more natural way as soon as possible the
team also experimented with making the
Avatar face respond to motor signals to
produce certain expressions
combining all these elements together
could one day give people who can't
speak the ability to communicate with
much more Nuance that is possible with
text alone
despite these advances the two systems
still have about a 25 error rate and
they speak at around half the average
speed for English speech as well as that
each of these systems has so far only
been tested with one person and we still
don't know exactly what the safest and
most accurate way of getting the most
relevant brain signals might be
still this Leap Forward in the speed
accuracy and vocabulary could be enough
to show that a mass-produced product is
feasible it could be enough to start
developing safe and practical Hardware
that's long lasting and easy for people
to use in their everyday lives
the next question is what the people who
need it actually want from these kinds
of systems and how best to turn
scientific progress on brain computer
interfaces like these into usable
technology that can improve the lives of
people around the world
that's great thank you Beth